[MUSIC PLAYING]
Most rivers, when you
get to a calm section,
you can rest a little bit.
But on Murch, that
calm, flat water
is definitely more terrifying
than any of the white water.
MAN: Being a kayaker in
Central Africa, inevitably,
you're going to have
crocs in the river.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Nile crocodiles are huge.
They can be up to 20 feet
long, and they'll hunt you.
They often hide under
water, waiting to strike.
And if a crocodile attacks you,
there's nothing you can do.
We were much more likely to
see a crocodile in a very, very
flat river with no current.
So this is the start of
what we call the supermarket.
It's very narrow.
The water's flowing slowly.
Lots of rocks for
the crocs to bake on.
So this is-- yeah.
I don't think I've ever gone
through here without a charge.
So hopefully, today
will be the first time.
But keep your eyes open,
guys, and scan at river level,
especially for,
like, open rocks.
It's normally where
they hang out.
MAN: So the supermarket
is where the crocs
hang out in order to feed.
You're the food in
their supermarket.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The risk of the
crocodile isn't when it's
sitting on the bank in the sun.
The risk is when it is in the
water and you can't see it.
Big [BLEEP] croc in this
eddy last time I was here.
Definitely, the
most jaw-droppingly
scary experience I've ever had.
Henry was talking us
through the experience.
We had a good
formation this morning.
We were able to just focus
on the sound of his voice
and focus on his direction in
order to not get overwhelmed.
And all of a sudden, you
hear this glorious roar
of whitewater, and you
know you're through it.
High five, guys.
But I didn't see,
like, a single croc.
Maybe that gave a false sense
of invincibility or something.
Murchison falls
definitely cemented us
feeling like a good solid team.
We were ready to paddle a bunch
of rivers, explore new places,
and meet new people.
That whole two months,
we were really living
that dream of exploration.
MAN: To the best
trip ever, gentlemen.
To the best trip ever.
[MUSIC PLAYING]